okay let's get started so hi everyone
welcome to CS 330 if you are expecting
to be in a different class and you're
probably in the wrong place
I am Chelsea Finn and I'm a professor in
the computer science department yeah so
let's get started
so first I'm gonna go over course
logistics and then we'll go over a
little bit of content to get started on
some some aspects for motivation for why
we care about all these house learning
in middle learning so first for
logistics some information and resources
so this is the full staff for the course
we have 40 A's I think one or two of
them are here today maybe you can kind
of stand up and introduce yourself and
then as great so those are the first and
last one I'm able to make it today but
there are also TAS for the course as
well there'll be great resources for you
as you go about taking the course the
course website is shown here and there's
a lot of information on the course
website beyond what will be kind of
covering in the logistics here also we
have a Piazza this will be for for
questions as they come up in the course
this is the staff mailing list as well
and each of us will be holding one hour
of office hours per week my office hours
are Wednesday after class and the other
office hours will be posted on the
course website
we'll have office hours for the first
time on Wednesday this week great so pre
represents an enrollment the main
prerequisite is something that is
machine learning experience basically
covering machine learning and
reinforcement learning CS 229 or
equivalent I me highly recommend having
some previous reinforcement learning
experience because a number a large
portion of the course will include
topics and reinforcement learning
if you're not currently enrolled please
fill out the enrollment form on the
website and we will kind of go through
that we do still have some open spots in
the course and we'll we'll go through
that probably around Tuesday or
Wednesday this week so please fill that
out as soon as possible if you're not
enrolled yeah and then if you filled out
the form and
receive apparition number yet it's
either because you filled out the form
very recently or because we weren't
quite sure if you had the kind of
necessary experience in order to succeed
to this class and we've said well we'll
get back to everyone by by Wednesday
this week okay all the luxuries are
being recorded and the lectures will be
internally released on canvas as soon as
the recording is available they'll also
be publicly released after the course
for the benefit of kind of the general
public
despite this kind of things like student
anonymity will be preserved in the
recording and so please still feel free
to ask questions throughout the course
as well there are around 20 remote
students from the Stanford center for
professional development that are
joining the course as well remotely and
SCPD is actually the the folks that will
be allowing for us to release all the
videos online after the course by
providing captioning services and other
things so if you have any any questions
about anything up here okay assignment
so the incitements will all require
training err all networks using
tensorflow and so if you're not familiar
with tensorflow already will be holding
a review session on Thursday of this
week and basically you should be able to
understand kind of an overview of
tensorflow
and if you don't understand an overview
of tensorflow i'd highly encourage you
to go to the review session and ask
plenty of questions this is kind of your
opportunity to to get information about
how to use tensorflow
if you aren't familiar with it already
topics that we're covering in this
course so the types of topic these are
all listed although kind of lecture
topics are listed on the course website
to include things like what is multi
test learning and meta learning the
basics of these algorithms including
various approaches ranging from blackbox
approaches optimization based approaches
metric learning methods as well how we
can view these types of methods in a
hierarchical Bayesian framework as kind
of learning priors or for multiple tasks
and using those priors topics like multi
task reinforcement learning goal
condition reinforced
Haruko reinforcement learning topics
metal reinforcement learning as well as
some open problems invited lectures and
research talks from faculty in the field
one thing worth noting here is there'll
be an emphasis on deep learning as kind
of indicated by the title of the course
as well as an emphasis on reinforcement
learning so a little under half of the
course is going to be kind of focusing
on different topics in reinforcement
learning because that is where some of
these some of these types of techniques
become a lot more interesting and a lot
more challenging topics we won't cover
do do kind of the constraints of how
much time we have in this course we
won't cover topics in Otto amel this
includes things like architecture search
like hyper parameter optimization and
learning optimizers but beyond that I
think we'll be covering most topics in
metal learning and multitask learning
but we'll also have an emphasis on deep
learning approaches so we won't be cut
like thoroughly covering things in like
things without you neural networks for
example and I know but I'll kind of
describe why later in this lecture okay
so the course format so we'll have three
types of course sessions we'll have nine
lectures that are kind of given by me I
will have seven student reading sessions
which will consist of presentations by
you presenting different papers and
we'll have a discussion of different
papers in the multi task learning and
meta learning literature and then we'll
also have three guest lectures all
students that are enrolled in the course
are responsible for giving one group
presentation of a paper and in these
kind of student reading sessions we'll
be presenting for papers and the papers
are all posted on the course website and
also further instructions on how to
actually prepare your presentation we'll
also is also posted on Piazza and beyond
even if you're not presenting a paper we
highly encourage actually to participate
in the discussion of the paper and come
to class so well the courses are being
recorded I think that you'll actually
get a lot more from the course if you
actually part actively participate in
various discussions of papers to better
understand the literature and
kind of dig into why these papers are
good or what their limitations are okay
and also this will change in future
offerings so in future offerings will
probably be introducing more lectures
into the course and fewer student
reading sessions as as years go on okay
more details on assignments so we're
gonna have three homework assignments
the first homework will cover things
ranging from multi tossed data
processing and black box metal learning
methods you'll actually be implementing
how to actually kind of go about
processing data in a multi task fashion
such that you can apply these types of
algorithms to them and also implementing
a black box metal learning algorithm and
homework two you'll be implementing
gradient based metal learning algorithms
as well as metric learning algorithms
and then in homework three that will be
on things like gold conditioned
reinforcement learning and multi task
reinforcement learning so you'll get the
opportunity to play around with all
these algorithms yourself and and see
how well they work on various domains
including like image classification
domains and simulated robotic control
domains and then lastly we'll have a
final project so this is gonna be a
research research level project of your
choice we encourage you to kind of
integrate any kind of research that
you're doing into this into this
research project for the course as long
as it's on the topics that are kind of
pertinent to the course things like
multi-touch learning and mendler nning
and for this you'll be allowed to form
groups of one to three students and
you're welcome to start early so you're
welcome to kind of start forming groups
now and start thinking about what what
you'll actually want to do for your
final project for grading it will be 20%
on your paper presentation which is in a
group 30% on homework 10% each as well
as 50% on the final project okay and
then you also give in five late days
across homeworks and your project paper
submission that you can kind of allocate
as you see fit depending on things
coming up great and then the last thing
is one more thing about the project is
that we'll also be posting kind of
guidelines for the project and we'll
have various milestones throughout the
course for you to propose your project
kind of I think like
communicate progress that you've made on
your project and then of course present
the final project the things that you
need to do today are sign up for Piazza
if you haven't already fill out your
paper presentation preferences so I we
have seven paper presentations with four
papers each so fill out your preferences
for which of those twenty-eight papers
you're most interested in presenting do
this by Thursday so that we can try to
get kind of sign assign those as quickly
as possible especially for the first
presentation which will be hot index
happening next week on Wednesday and so
these the instructions for the
presentations and also how to sign up is
on Piazza and then lastly start forming
final product groups if you want to work
in a group and if you're not familiar
with tensorflow review review the the
tensorflow
intro or go to the review session on
Thursday okay anything else about
logistics any questions yeah so we will
be providing the a lot of infrastructure
around the around these kind of
different problems in tensorflow if you
want to do everything in PI torch and
kind of produce the deliverables that
the kind of the curves that you need to
deliver and and produce as part of your
write-up of the assignment that is
that's fine that's completely fine so if
you want to only use PI torch I you can
do that but it will probably involve
writing a fair amount of code in
addition to the code that you would have
to write in tensorflow because of the
the infrastructure being written and
that's our flow yeah
so the first homework will be runnable
on a laptop the second homework will
will be a little bit more compute heavy
and we're still looking into various
various cloud compute options for that
that we'll be able to provide for people
that don't have GPUs for example to be
able to run their code on and the third
one will probably be run a bowl on a
laptop as well but we're still
finalizing at that assignment yeah we'll
be using tensor flow but not tensor flow
- yeah
that's a good question let me get back
to you on that I'll post will post it on
the project guidelines on kind of what
we allow in that regard okay two more
things first ask plenty of questions you
guys are off to a great start and I mean
this course is really for your purpose
not for not for my purpose just to sit
here to stand here and and and talk and
so if there are things that are unclear
things that you're kind of curious to
learn more about please raise your hand
and ask questions and second this course
is new it's the first time that that
we're offering it and so as a result the
course will likely be rough around the
edges I in comparison to courses that
are run every single quarter and so
please bear with me and the and the rest
of the course stuff and this is kind of
all the more reason for you to ask
plenty of questions as we kind of figure
out how the course is going to be run
throughout the quarter okay great so now
I'd like to talk about well like why
should we actually care about
multitasking and meta learning and and
what are the sorts of things that you'll
actually be learning in this course and
what I was like to start this discussion
with is actually talk about some of my
own research and some of the reasons why
I care about multitask learning and meta
learning and then I'll talk about kind
of brought more broadly where these
types of algorithms are being used and
why they're really important
and a really fundamental aspect of
machine learning research okay
so one of the questions in my research
group that we like to think about is how
can we enable agents to learn skills in
the real world and what I mean by the
real world is I mean robots robots like
like these robots that can use tools to
lift up objects and put them into bowls
that can play with children's toys that
can watch kind of a video of a human
doing something and learn from from that
and that you might ask well why robots
that seems like robots might be a lot of
work to deal with and I think that I had
the reason why studying robots is really
exciting is that robots can teach us
things about intelligence okay this
might sound a little silly also because
robots are not very smart but I think
that robots are faced with many of the
challenges that humans are faced with as
they learn and develop over the course
of their lifetime robots are faced with
the real world and they have to deal
with it
robots have to be able to generalize
across tasks across objects across
environments in order to be successful
in real-world settings they need some
sort of common sense understanding in
order to do well and lastly supervision
can't really readily be taken for
granted it's not easy to just provide
labels or even figure out what labels
mean in the context of getting a robot
to do something so I think that if you
can build intelligent robots in the real
world you can kind of convince yourself
that you've solved some important
problems regarding intelligence though
of course my goal in this lecture isn't
to convince you to work on robots my
goal is instead to kind of discuss some
of the challenges that come up and and
kind of guide this towards multi house
on hand meddler and can't describe where
this where this fits in so I will start
with a bit of a story here so the beauty
of my PhD like five or so years ago I
was in a lab at Berkeley and there was
this research product that was going on
whoops the video isn't playing here we
go there's recess research project going
on trying to get the robot to learn how
to assemble this toy airplane by putting
the wheels into the correct
and the robot here is is learning how to
do the task through trial and error at
the beginning the robot is kind of
started with very random motions and
over time is able to kind of figure out
how to do the task successfully so I
thought this is this is really cool the
robot is actually kind of you can see it
kind of learning really this is 20x real
time but if you kind of watch the robot
in the real time you'd actually be able
see the robot learning in real time do
trial and error I guess what's really
exciting about this is the robot isn't
it isn't just kind of this isn't just an
algorithm for learning how to do that
task it's an algorithm for that can do
really a wide range of manipulation
tasks and so in principle this algorithm
could be applied to a wide range of
settings now one of the things that was
a little bit disappointing about this is
that it turns out the robots the robot
essentially had its eyes closed it was
doing this completely blind and just
kind of essentially blindly trying to
get the I get the wheels into the right
place and so kind of this motivated some
of the work that I did if you knee of my
PhD where we wanted to get the robot to
do things while also seeing do things
that required vision in this case it
needed to actually see to figure out
where the shape sorting cube was in
order to figure out where to where to
place it and again here you can see it
kind of learning over time starting from
scratch figuring out how to get the the
block into the respective hole and so I
guess one things that I mentioned here
is the kind of the reason why these
sorts of algorithms I think are really
exciting is that the same sort of
algorithm the same reinforcement
learning algorithm can be applied to
many different tasks so you can't you
don't just learn how to insert the block
into the shape sorting queue which it
kind of eventually figures out here and
here's actually that kind of the final
policy where I'm holding the cube in
front of the robot it can also be
applied to learn things like placing the
claw the toy hammer underneath the nail
or ice create a cap onto a bottle or
it's kind of the most challenging thing
that we got it to do with this
particular algorithm was to use a
spatula to lift up an object into a bowl
and the site this house is actually
really challenging because here the
robot has to be fairly aggressive in
maneuvering the spatula underneath the
object so this was really exciting at
least we were
really excited about some of these
results and there were a range of people
that built upon the method as well
getting robots to do other tasks like
using a hockey stick to hit a puck into
a goal opening a door throwing objects
and so while it kind of seems like this
is pretty exciting and indeed at the
time it was very exciting
we have a bit of an issue the issue is
that the robot didn't learn how to use
spatulas lift objects at the bowls it
learned how to use that spatula to look
that object into that bowl if you gave
it a different Bowl or a different
spatula or even a different tablecloth
in the background the policy wouldn't
generalize the policy would fail because
it was trained in exactly that
environment so this doesn't necessarily
seem like that much of an issue so you
could just say well why don't we just
give the robot more spatulas and more
bowls and more tablecloths and have it
just learn and in more settings and this
may be this is kind of an easy problem
to solve in many ways you'd be right
that would be kind of be a reasonable
approach to try to learn a more
generalizable policy but the tricky
thing is that this algorithm was
designed kind of with the intention of
it being a single task learning
algorithm in a single environment and so
let's kind of look at this so behind the
scenes if you look at one of these
algorithms especially algorithms that
kind of require moving objects in
different ways this is kind of what the
learning process looks like behind the
scenes you the robot kind of tries to do
the task and then human comes in and
puts the puck back and so by by nature
of kind of focusing on the single task
learning problem the methods aren't
actually scalable to learning more tasks
without actually starting again from
scratch and having my friend Dave again
here kind of repeatedly reset the robot
after each trial and so you can hear is
making more worker than the robot
arguably and it's also just kind of more
generally it's not practical to collect
a lot of data this way so to build
algorithms that are effective at
learning across many different tasks we
need it in many ways fundamentally
rethink how we're actually kind of
these algorithms in the first place okay
the issue here was that relied on very
detailed supervision very detailed
guidance that can't be scaled to many
different tasks and this is not just a
problem with robot learning it's also a
problem with kind of standard
reinforcement learning algorithms as
well kind of things that learn how to
play Atari games and locomotion they
require a lot and a lot of data a lot of
supervision in the form of reward
functions in order to learn effectively
it's also not just a problem with
reinforcement learning so if you think
about some of the biggest successes in
supervised learning systems these
systems are able to handle much more
diverse data and learn across different
users different languages but in many
ways these systems are still learning
one task starting from scratch with very
detailed supervision so those like these
systems are what I would call
specialists and that they're trained for
kind of in a single task learning
setting instead if we kind of look about
think about well how would we get a get
a more generalist system that's kind of
in many ways part of what this course is
about in some ways and kind of one way
to get inspiration for this is we could
look at kind of how humans learn humans
don't learn in the settings that I
mentioned before humans learn kind of by
rolling around on the floor by
interacting and kind of a very rich and
diverse environment humans are what I
would call generalists humans learn many
simple skills such as crawling picking
up objects playing with toys before
trying to learn much more complex tasks
and and perhaps to build machine
learning systems that are generalists we
need them to look a bit more like this
systems that can learn could build upon
previous experience to learn new things
more quickly and learn many simple
things before trying to learn more
complex things and so if kind of if we
make an analogy to that kind of the way
that machine learning systems learn to
how humans learn this would kind of be
like if we want to train a system to
play go from scratch this would be kind
of like trying to start from scratch and
have a baby learn how to play go for
example and so this seems a little bit
silly or a little bit off in some ways
potentially
okay so that was that's a bit why some
of the reasons why I care about
multitask learning and and medal earning
why should if you don't even if you
don't care about robots why should why
should we generally care about these
algorithms and unfortunately there's a
lot of reasons to care beyond robots and
beyond kind of trying to build more
general-purpose machine learning systems
and first I want to start by why do we
care about deep multi house learning in
MEDLINE why do we care about deep
learning in particular actually before I
move on are there any questions on the
part that I mentioned before on the
robots hi so if we kind of go back at
this point like ten years the standard
approach to computer vision looks
something like this where you took some
image you then tried to extract some
mid-level feature some features such
things called hog features or six
features these are features that are
designed by hand vite vite researchers
and then on top of those features you
may have more mid-level features like
deformable parts models kind of as
visualized on the right and then on top
of that you would have a little
classifier like a support vector machine
on top of those features and now if you
kind of fast forward ten years and until
now basically what modern computer
vision looks like is something that is
more like this something where you take
an image and you pass it through a
neural network and have it produce the
desired output and essentially kind of
one of the most salient differences
between these two things is that deep
learning allows us to handle
unstructured inputs it allows us to
operate directly on the image pixels
that are shown on the left it allows us
to directly operate on things like
language like sensor readings without
requiring hand engineered features like
hog or sifter or deformable part models
and also with less domain knowledge so
it means that we can kind of apply the
single class of techniques of neural
networks essentially to a wide range of
problem domains so so that's one kind of
benefit of deep learning systems and the
second benefit of course is that they
work really well in
in a variety of different situations so
if you look at results on the image net
data set over the course of around five
years I look at the error rate this dot
right here is Alex net and in 2012 this
was the in many ways while the first
neural networks that was successfully
demonstrated on the image net dataset
and before that things were plot toeing
around 0.25 0.3 and then kind of there
was this really this mode shift this
kind of mode transition where after 2012
I think most if not all of the the dots
are deep learning models and of course
were were way more successful than than
previous approaches that we're relying
on hand engineered features and this
isn't a specific to computer vision so
in machine translation for example in in
2016 Google started switching Google
Translate to a system based on neural
networks in this case PMT is phrase
based machine translation where as GMT
or nmt more broadly neural machine
translation you start starts using
neural networks and we see a pretty big
difference this is the human evaluation
scores we see kind of ranging from 50
percent to 80 percent improvements by
using neural networks ok so this is why
teeth learning and kind of in in two
slides there are other reasons as well
now why deep multitask learning and
metal learning so if there's something
that we've learned from deep learning is
that we can if we kind of give these
neural networks large and diverse data
sets they can achieve broad
generalization so for example the image
that data set or things like like
transformers GPG - these have been kind
of extremely successful at producing
models that generalize across across
many different images across many
different inputs but the caveat is here
is that they require a large and diverse
data set and what if you don't have a
large data set then you're you're in a
bit of trouble these are domains that in
there are wide range of domains where we
don't have large data sets
things like
medical imaging like robotics like I
mentioned before like education for you
don't have a lot of data for each
individual student that you're trying to
teach medicine recommendation systems
translation systems you don't have a lot
of paired data for every single pair of
languages that's out there
and so as a result it's impractical to
learn from scratch for each disease for
each robot for each person for each
language really for each task and so
instead that's where these multi toss
learning techniques can come in and ok
so beyond the kind of de settings where
we don't have a large data set what if
your data has a long tail what if your
data distribution looks something like
this where the y-axis is showing the
number of data points and the x axis is
showing different objects that you've
encountered in the world or different
interactions with people or words that
you've heard over time or driving
situations etc when you're in kind of a
variety of the situations on the look
you're kind of in good shape this looks
a lot like what you've seen before
whereas if you're on the right and and
kind of the tail on the right that's
where these algorithms start to break
down where supervised learning methods
really struggle to perform well and this
is for example this is a really big
problem in autonomous driving where cars
can handle a wide variety of very common
situations but when they see very weird
situations humans can handle them
perfectly well but these cars really
struggle ok and lastly what if you need
to quickly learn something new what if
you had previous knowledge and you'll
holland's learn something new about a
person for a new task about a new
environment without trading from scratch
it turns out that people are pretty good
at this and in particular let's see how
good you are at it so I want to give you
a little test the left side is showing
your training data there's six data
points you have three paintings that are
from Brock and three paintings that are
from Cezanne and your goal is to be able
to classify the test data point that is
on the right and so if you think the
painting on the right is from Brock
raise your hand and you think it is from
Cezanne raise your hand
great okay I think that there are more
four for Brock which is the correct
answer
the way that you can tell that is you
can kind of look at the the types of
kind of straight lines and curved lines
that are prominent in the image and so
how do you actually go about doing this
so this this is the kind of problem
that's known as few shot learning where
you're only given a few data points in
this case six data points and your goal
is to make predictions about new data
points from that very small data set the
way that you compost is is that you
weren't learning from scratch you have
previous experience you haven't probably
seen these exact paintings before and
you probably haven't necessarily even
seen paintings from these painters
before but you've seen paintings before
you've probably seen kind of you know
what objects are you know what textures
are and through that previous experience
you were able to quickly identify the
painting corresponding to the course
line to the correct painter okay so all
these things if you want more
general-purpose machine learning systems
if you don't have large data sets if
your data has long tails if you wanna be
able to quickly learn something new
these are all settings where elements of
multitask learning and meta learning can
come into play and can help us out and
basically make machine learning more
effective in these problem settings any
questions on on these four things before
I move on
okay um so I've been talking a lot about
multitasking but what what is a task and
this is this lecture something that's
really important because a task isn't
necessarily what we kind of associate
with in kind of the English language for
now the way I'm gonna define a task is
something that takes us in a data set
takes as input a data set and a loss
function and gives you a model this is
we're gonna kind of generalize this
later and make it potentially a bit more
formal later in the course but for now
this is what we're gonna be considering
essentially you can view a task as a
machine learning problem where you have
some data of some loss function you want
to optimize that loss function in order
to produce a model and so what this
means is that if you have different
tasks different tasks would vary in
different ways they could vary for
different objects like maybe one task is
to come up be able to classify between
one type of cat and another type of cat
whereas another type of another task
corresponds to being able to classify
between different types of water bottles
so in this case different tasks would
correspond to different objects they
could also correspond to different
people if you want to be able to kind of
personalize these systems to be able to
handle and effectively make predictions
about new users I think he correspond to
different objectives
maybe you in one case you want to be
able to classify the cost by someone's
age versus you want to be able to
classify someone's height from from an
image those are kind of different
objectives that you want to be able to
accomplish it could be something like
different lighting conditions of your
model different words that you're
encountering different languages that
your accounting tell them it can
encapsulate kind of a wide range of
different things so not just different
tasks as you would think of a task as in
kind of in English I really it can vary
in a wide range of ways questions on
that
yeah so it could correspond to a
different really different data set or a
different loss function or both so for
example in the case where you have
different objects that would manifest in
potentially the same loss function but
like be able to match labels but a
different data set whereas something
that looks like different objectives
like classifying between one thing
versus another thing that might be
something that looks like different loss
functions but the same data says yes I
think that that is a case you could also
have one task that kind of like a cross
entropy loss and another task that has
like a mean squared error loss for
example all day of course you can
generalize both of those is like log
likelihood yeah yeah so you could say
that that that is that is precisely a
new task you could also I think that
there is kind of this fluid notion of
what is a new task force versus it's
just kind of lumped into a single task
learning problem and I'll actually talk
about that kind of more fluidness in a
couple slides but that is kind of one
thing that you could view those
different tasks okay so in multi test
learning and meta learning there's one
critical assumption this is kind of
where some of the bad news comes in
which is that different tasks need to
share some structure in order to get a
benefit from these algorithms if the
tasks don't share it's a toss that
you're trying to learn across don't
share any structure then you're better
off just using single task learning
independently on each of those tasks and
kind of then morphing those into a
single model if you want to produce a
single model the good news is though is
that there are many tasks in fast
distributions that have shared structure
even if they don't kind of on the
surface appear to have
shared structure so as one kind of
simple example here something like
screwing a cap on to a lid versus
screwing a bottle cap versus screwing a
kind of a pepper grinder all shower
similar structure in terms of the
underlying motion that needs to be
performed this is maybe an example where
the shared structure is more explosive
and even if there are tasks that are
seemingly unrelated there is things that
are still underlying various structure
that's still underlying those tasks
because the laws of physics are kind of
underlying the real data that that we
have people are all organisms that have
intentions and so even if two people are
very different they still have some
commonalities the rules of English are
underlying all like well not all but a
fair amount of english-language data and
languages are kind of developed for
similar purposes and so on so in these
kind of may seem like superficial
relationships between different tasks
but in reality this leads to far greater
structure than having completely random
tasks because completely random tasks
would essentially look like completely
random inputs random labels and in
practice kind of the real world is
underlying a lot of the data that we're
looking at yeah
it applies to metal learning as well
yeah so I'll give problem definitions of
multitask learning and metal learning on
the next slide but in essence like in
order metal learning is all about kind
of learning the structure underlying
tasks such that you can more quickly
learn a new task and if you can't if
there isn't any shared structure then
you won't be able to learn more quickly
than learning from scratch
okay so let's informally go over some of
the problem definitions in the coming
lectures actually in the next lecture
we'll formalize these lectures these
definitions these problem definitions a
lot more but just kind of just to give
you a rough idea of what I'm talking
about with these with these kinds of
problem definitions here's kind of
roughly what things look like so you can
think of the multitask learning problem
as trying to learn all of the tasks that
you're provided with more quickly or
more proficiently than learning the
tasks independently from one another and
then what the meta learning problem is
looking at is given data or experience
on a set of previous tasks that you're
given you want to be able to learn a new
task more quickly and are more
proficiently than learning from scratch
by leveraging your experience on the
previous tasks so essentially the
difference between these two things is
that the first one you're trying to
learn a set of tasks and do well on
those training tasks and then in the
second problem setting you're trying to
use experience on training tasks in
order to do it well at new tasks and in
order to basically be able to more
quickly learn new tasks given a data set
and in this course we won't necessarily
be covering everything that's considered
a multi test learning algorithm or a
meta learning algorithm will be really
anything that solves one of these two
problem statements will be fair game for
including in the course so the things
that allow you to build on previous
experience to quickly learn new tasks
even if they aren't through learning to
learn techniques I'll try to touch on
them in this course questions on these
problem statements yeah
yeah so I guess in many ways I think
that this is the a form of the
transfer learning problem statement
where you want to take some data and use
that use knowledge acquired from that
data to do well at other tasks I think
that one aspect about this problem
statement is that you want to be able to
learn a new task more quickly whereas in
transfer learning you may also want to
be able to just form a well and perform
a new task well in zero shot where you
kind of just want to share
representations I actually kind of view
transfer learning as something that
encapsulates both of these things where
you're thinking about how you can
transfer information between different
tasks and that could actually also
correspond to the multitask learning
problem as well as the meta learning
problem yes
yeah that's a good question so I guess
what I'm defining here is the the meta
learning problem and I think that meta
learning algorithms are all learning to
learn and they solve this particular
problem and they're not the only way to
solve this particular problem
does that answer your question that's a
good point yeah so in principle you
could still perform medal learning in
the context of a single task and what
you would be doing in that case is
probably actually in some ways breaking
down that single task into sub tests or
into kind of sub components
and then using that when kind of when
you're facing something new in that
single task using that experience to
more quickly learn in the future yes
that's a good point the tasks in some
ways could be something that's kind of
leading to your underlying problem yeah
yeah so formally cover the distinction
with domain annotation in the next
lecture but in some ways they're similar
I guess in some ways one is more
specific than the other and in some ways
it's kind of the opposite so in domain
adaptation you typically do want to cut
it's kind of a form of chance for
learning in some ways where you want to
transfer from one to another one thing
and I guess when I get into the more
formal definitions of these problems
this will come become more clear one
thing you typically see in the meta
learning problem is that the tasks that
you're seeing at test time you assume to
be in the distribution of the tasks that
you're seeing during training whereas
many techniques in domain adaptation are
considering a setting where your test
domain it may be out of distribution
from what you're seeing during training
and yeah so that's that's in many ways
one of those distinctions there
okay now one question that was asked a
bit before is kind of I think in the
context of circuit says what is it is it
something a single task learning problem
or a multi test learning problem in some
ways this gets gets down to the question
of doesn't multitask learning reduced to
just a single task learning problem and
in particular what you could do is you
could just say I have a data set for
each task and we're going to take the
union of those data sets into a single
data set and likewise I'll take the loss
function for each and just kind of sum
and get a loss function and now we have
a single task learning problem where we
have one data set and one loss function
and we're done and in many ways yes I
arguing the data across the task and
learning is is one very successful
approach for multi task learning but we
can often do better and in particular we
can exploit the fact that we know the
data is coming from different tasks and
use this to achieve greater performance
and basically exploit that structure in
the optimization in order to perform
better okay no I think the one of the
last things I want to cover is is why
now why should we be studying this topic
now rather than in in ten years or ten
years ago well people are actually
starting this problem a long time ago so
this is 12 years ago at this point 22
years ago at this point and this is by a
survey in rich career thinking about how
we can train tasks and parallel while
using shared representations they you
can do multi task inductive transfer and
add extra tasks to a back propagation
neural network in 1998 Sebastian Thrun
was thinking about this problem where we
want to be able to exploit an enormous
amount of training data and experiences
that stem from from one another stem
from other related learning tasks in
order to generalize to new tasks even
from a single training example and
actually even earlier in 1992 Sanjeev
NGO and yasho and others were lucky
about the possibility of learning a
learning role that can be used to solve
new tasks so these ideas are by no means
new and people have been studying these
for for a very long time at this point
but I think that right now is actually
particularly exciting time to be
studying these algorithms because I
think that they're starting and actually
continuing to play a fundamental role in
machine learning research especially
with the advent of powerful neural
network function approximator is the
amount of compute that we have right now
as well as the the kind of datasets that
we're looking at and so as some examples
are very recent works that have kind of
leverage some of these algorithms to do
well here's a paper looking at machine
translation across over a hundred
languages thinking about how we can
learn algorithms algorithms surpass
strong base base lines that use only two
languages here are some work from my lab
that I actually previewed at the
beginning is we can kind of use these
types of algorithms to learn from a
video of a human so is this like one of
your TAS who's showing a video to the
robot at performing a task and then the
robot can use that video to learn learn
a policy that can successfully place the
peach into the bowl just from that
single example and the policy can
generalize to different positions of the
of the bowl so we'll cover kind of the
algorithms underlying this and people
have also looked at multi domain
learning so in here different tasks
would correspond to different domains
and they this paper they constructed
different simulated domains with
different textures different
environments and they show that they
could use only this data in simulation
in order to enable a quadcopter to fly
in the real world and navigate in the
real world and actually just like within
the past two days this paper was
published on how YouTube is using multi
task objective multitasking multi
objective systems
in order to make recommendations and
being developing algorithms that can
handle multiple competing objectives so
I think that these these types of
algorithms are playing a huge role in
robotics in in kind of deployed YouTube
machine learning systems as well as in
other research they'll also think that
they're playing an increasing role in
machine learning research so if you look
at Google search queries over the course
of the past few years we see a trend
that looks like this where blue is meta
learning and red is multitask learning
and we see an increase starting around
2014-2015 and if you also look at kind
of paper citations for things that cover
things like fine tuning we see an
increasing trend metal earning
algorithms as well as multitask learning
algorithms you see that these algorithms
are becoming of increasing interest and
I think that's because these algorithms
can be really important in the future
for enabling things like learning from
small data sets etc and lastly I think
that the success of multi-touch learning
algorithms and meta learning algorithms
will be really critical for making deep
learning more widely accessible as I
mentioned before the kind of settings
work deep learning has been very
successful before settings where you
have 1.2 million images 40.8 million
pairs sentences 300 hours of label data
and in a wide range of settings that's
just not feasible so if we look at for
example diabetic retinopathy detection
data set it has around 35,000 label data
sets I think labeled images I think this
is actually one of the larger medical
image data sets and yet it still has two
orders of magnitude less data than kind
of the data sets on the left on the top
there was a really interesting paper
that was looking at reinforcement
learning for epilepsy treatment in that
case they had less than an hour of data
and in some of the work that we've done
in robotics we've had less than 15
minutes of data per individual tasks
that we want the robot to learn so if we
care about kind of making these making
deep learning algorithms in the success
of deep learning more widely accessible
to these types of domains then it can be
critical to build these kinds of
algorithms and lastly beyond the things
that I've talked about there's still
many open questions and challenges and
we'll
house learning and I think that that
makes it a really exciting thing to
study right now because there's a lot of
problems to be solved great so that's it
for today as a reminder please do these
four things please sign up for paper
presentations sign up for Piazza etc and
on Wednesday I'll be covering multitask
learning and better learning basics I'll
see you on Wednesday